I said during our hot topics meeting
that lap dancing isn't cheating but come
to think of it I've never seen a lap
dance would you like to see yeah
[Applause]
it's going to be us just helping people
figure out the things that maybe they're
have questions about
yeah questions like I think people name
both people naked well class seems to be
in session on The View a survey
[Laughter]
of 6 000 Americans found that 70 percent
Have Cheated at Bachelor or Bachelorette
party I said during our hot topics
meeting that lap dancing isn't cheating
but come to think of it I've never seen
a lap dance so maybe it is you said
Manny Halston could have a lap dance and
that wasn't cheap
well I tend to be a little jealous I've
changed my mind because I don't really
know what that looks like well enter
Whoopi who's apparently Been Waiting For
a Moment Like This do you know how long
I've been here willing and able to give
a demonstration no one will forget
especially not Sunny hosted would you
like to see
okay let me get the hell out of the way
well my behind's not that big first I
start I'm looking at you okay
I start
Ed
[Applause]
and then it's me going down
and then I go back on the side
bring your craft bring your A game and
the rest will happen
yeah that just happened so what's the
final verdict from Sonny
[Music]
of course it was Sarah Haynes who had
fans asking questions last week it's
unreal it always is
so apparently there is a show coming
called the Golden bachelor which I'm
calling the old people's Bachelor yeah
more relatable that's Sarah moments away
from a not safe for work comment leading
producers to cut off her mic and
instructing Whoopi to throw it to
commercial they're telling me the
fantasy suite is being them nappy
the fancy you know
60 year olds they run marathons
we'll be right back
this is a really great job we know who
we are we know what our place is in the
world and we try to do the best we can
and any longtime fan of the talk show
will agree that he got Winner's best is
more than plenty
no I'm doing it to you okay
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you